my name is Alex Sexton i just presented
on building your own component library
I'm from Austin Texas and I am an
engineered stripe that payments company
a lot of my job focuses around
JavaScript development and front-end
development but I'm also very active in
the open source community which is where
I really got into JavaScript I helped
with the jQuery foundation and the dojo
foundation and I really enjoy open
source in general I'm really excited
about where the web is going and where
javascript is going definitely a
ubiquitous language that that people are
still coming around to but is is really
I mean they don't really have a choice
either way because of its ubiquity but I
think it will really stand up to the
test of time with things like azum and
things that will really help push the
JavaScript performance view into
competition with things like native
which I think it already can do but in
the future should be the web winning
again case I've really enjoyed Buenos
Aires so far I've had from Texas and so
the meat situation is correct here and
I've enjoyed all the food very much so
far but also feels like a very friendly
city I visit cities often I feel like an
outsider and I definitely feel welcome
and comfortable walking through the
streets here and that's something that
that not every city can say she has comp
Argentina is definitely one of the best
JavaScript conferences but I think I've
been to quite a few j/s comps in
particular and this is definitely up
there with the best of them the food and
the projectors are crazy Guillermo is
crazy I really really have been having a
great time